holiday retail sales set a new record
this year shoppers spent more than eight
hundred billion dollars
some reports say that's up almost five
percent from last year online purchases
rose more than eighteen percent the
record sales mean retailers will deal
with a huge number of returns though
forty five percent of consumers will
return at least one item between
December 26 and December 31st they will
be part of the ninety billion dollars of
returns over the entire holiday season
that is forcing shops to find new ways
to make returns convenient fortune
senior editor at large Lea Gallagher is
here with more Lee good morning good
morning so we know we want to get it
quickly when we're talking about
shipping but what about the returns how
are they changing the returns have been
a huge headache for the consumer for the
retailer's as well and as online
shopping has grown it's just become a
huge point of friction in the process
the retailers have spent the past few
years really trying to address this
because it's not good for them if this
is gonna be such a huge part of their
business they need to find a way to deal
with it right and the consumer by the
way we have been so spoiled that we
expect everything to be seamless yeah
and easy and you know they have to they
have to meet that need so there's all
kinds of creative ways to process
returns this year we're starting to see
more of them a big thing is the movement
to buy online and return in-store so
that's actually easier for the consumer
in many ways it's also cheaper for the
retailer brings the cost down yeah a lot
of companies will have kiosks walmart
has kiosks in its store it's promising
you can return in under five minutes
amazon of course bought Whole Foods so
now you can return at Whole Foods but
Amazon in this never did we think we
would see this has forged a relationship
with Kohl's where you can actually now
also buy on Amazon and return at Kohl's
and also lockers and you know the whole
just really easier and make it easier
Jim's other stores you can return
anywhere physically and then of course a
lot of retailers are extending the
length of time that you have and paying
for shipping doing everything they can
to make it easy it's still going to
require an errand which is what trips me
and I always thought it was a big no-no
because I actually do return things I
order online back to the physical store
so it's good to hear that they welcome
they want that it's better for them are
some
online policies changing now that more
people are shifting to online shopping
yeah they're changing a little bit like
extending the window and having the
labels that you can print out at home of
course then you need a printer but
they're doing everything they can
because this is all about what they call
reverse logistics it's bringing that
product back through the cycle of
inventory and logistics and the customer
doesn't care about reverse logistics all
the customer cares about we don't care
about your inventory we just want this
to be taken care of and so in a lot of
people as you just said return it's what
many people are doing this week I mean
I'm I returned things yesterday shopping
what are some of the third-party vendors
out there that are helping people return
things you guys were talking about that
during the commercial I had no idea what
that was all about well that's the other
thing there's been this whole cottage
industry that sprung up to help
retailers address this problem so
anytime retailers are spending any time
anyone spending a lot of money on
something there's a big headache
there's always entrepreneurs that come
in and try to make that easier and take
a piece of that margin and so there's
companies that are helping retailers
handle the returns for customers a
company called happy returns there are
companies that are actually trying to
make it at the front end easier to know
what you're buying so reducing the
likelihood of a risk so they make so how
does it work I mean if I I hate
returning things would they send
somebody to my apartment and pick up no
it's not about that it's nice to have an
errand taking the the pressure off of
the retailer they don't have to handle
that you can go to a kiosk in a mall or
something like that but then there are
ways that you know a lot of retailers
are being told put better photos online
in the first place so there's a lot of
innovation in that there's a lot of
innovation around 3d being able to put
yourself in the clothes online or look
at the furniture how it will look in
your space and so those things are
important because you know the end goal
would be to reduce the amount of returns
in the first place exactly need in the
holidays you're desperate you're under
that time crunch anyway I'll just buy it
and they can always return it or I can
always return it that return likelihood
it goes up during the holiday season
since of all the pressures and all the
convenience that it offers but none of
the gifts I received I'm rich now
[Laughter]
Gallagher thank you very much happy new
year thanks to you too